it's concert film and I'm Ennis with my
friend's brother Adam Larry and it's a
it's a 3d film and it's hopefully it's
gonna rock the house the best seat in
the house the viewer coming to this film
will have the best seat in the house at
AU to cancer so much of say watching
concert films reduces the band you know
makes them smaller they put some in your
living room and you see this it it
really gives the band scanner
perspective we have high-powered
computers on every camera rig and it's
really allowing us to shoot and make
sure that every shot is perfect just the
way your eyes would see them so it's
extremely comfortable to watch and in
this case it's like you're standing
right next to Bono or the edge or you're
in a crowd of 90,000 people in Buenos
Aires know you're gonna take off the
glasses right put on the 3d these are
three days I've been wearing 3d for
quite a while well it wasn't our idea
I mean Catherine our director and came
to us with the project and she said it's
it's gonna hopefully be a great record
of you know YouTube playing at their
best so we signed up and I think she was
right if nothing else it is a great
record of what we did during that time
is that these crazy people arrived one
day and said you know we got that we
want to do 3d we're building these
cameras you know we're doing it ready
for the sports world the Modell family
and the Shapiro family and you know we
want to offer to you guys to play with
first so really
okay you know that sounds good to us and
literally we we then got pretty serious
once we realized we did a test we
realized it was going to work and then
we got pretty serious about going for it
and making it katherine Owens the
director was like she just really pushed
it down our throat something we were on
tour we didn't really want to take on
another project we thought no not
another concert film that's boring but
she kind of showed us some test shots
and kind of convinced us that it was
really worth doing I mean the other nice
thing about it was it's also a concert
film at the outdoor show and the outdoor
show didn't play in America so it's a
chance for American audiences to see see
what they missed